hello everyone and welcome to the 2019
isle of man open tournament this is the
first time that the players are not
competing only for for ratings money and
prestige but also this time he who wins
the tournament gets a spot on the in
defeated candidates tournament 2020 so
it's a really strange but also very nice
if you've caught a I caught the
interview with fede president Arkady
dvorkovich he mentioned that he well he
and probably someone who decides on
these matters in fee day I decided that
the terminus was a very well organized
and that the attendance is a lot of very
strong grandmaster so they have decided
to grant the winner of this tournament
at the spot in the candidates tournament
and also he who wins the second place
will get it will get to be considered
maybe as a wild card along with someone
who who won third place in the World Cup
and along with someone who is won third
place that I believe in the Grand Prix
so that being said a hundred and fifty
four players will be competing for this
spot in the candidates tournament the
prize fund is four hundred and thirty
two thousand dollars and first place is
a seventy thousand dollars so the
players get a hundred minutes for the
game for the first 40 moves then they
are awarded additional fifty minutes and
and there is a there is a thirty Seconds
increment start starting from one as
usual so without further ado let's check
it out I don't have a fresh photo of
Magnus he shaved his beard so if I get
one I will use it but up until then we
are going to have to use this one so
with the white pieces crossed and opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to f3 and we have d5 the Queens
gambit declined is on the board we have
knife to c3 and now Knight B to d7
Carlsen trades once in the center with C
captures he captures and Bishop to g5
and here c6 strengthening in the center
crossings opponent is your EKU's above
very strong Ukrainian Grandmaster a he
is 29 years old at the moment he became
famous not famous but well-known to the
world
some 15 years
in 2004 when he defeated Sergei
hurricane with the black pieces but okay
Queen to c2 by crossing with h6 pushing
back the Bishop Bishop to h4 end now
even g5 with Bishop to g3 and night to
h5 gonna go for that
Bishop air right away with queenside
castle by Carlsen in mountain Knight
captures on g3 with H cactus and g3 and
now nights to b6 so usable one across
from the bishop pair cost no longer has
the dark square bishop but he wasted a
lot of moves on doing that age six g5
wasted a lot of moves with his a knight
which is no longer on the board now he
plays Knight to b6 and he wants to get a
very nice outpost for his knight on c4
or if across and once he might want to
play b3 at some point but that's
weakened the Queen side a bit too much
you're gonna be very weak on the dark
squares so II four by Carlsen
and now Bishop to e6 again just
strengthening here and coup Zubov
already had this position on the board
during the 2019 Hungarian Team
Championship which means cross and
prepared for this game very well and in
that game aku's both played this game
against Gobber Nagi where Knights thief
I was played also e captures and e5 is a
known move but cross and plays Bishop to
d3 it's a new move in the position and
as of move 13 we have a completely new
game and as soon as cross and plated
crucible replied with Queen to f6 saying
that this does not surprise him and here
cousin
spent well a fair amount of time I
believe some 15 minutes deciding on what
to do next
it's hard to say but probably maybe he
forgot his preparation as Queen to f6 is
the engine stop recommend the recommend
that replied the bishop to d3
but either way maybe he was just
double-checking for for some ideas but
in the end he pushed a 5 he decided to
close the position you could also try
and trade everything each character's
Knight captures Knight captures Bishop
captures and rook he1 claiming that you
are better here for example after Bishop
d7 you can go Queen to e2 and now not
allow black the castle as you would just
lose a bishop here but then Bishop
captures an a2 and we get this really
crazy position where blacks King is
stuck in the center of the board but
White's King doesn't
have all that many squares either and
it's gonna be well it's just gonna be a
very active game so Crossan prefers to
keep everything solid he pushes v5
pushes the black queen back Queen to g7
and then now Knight to h2 preparing to
pull it upon all the way to a4 and the
black prevents this by playing g4 pretty
much blissing it out now f4 will be met
with the G captors on f3 and poisson
which is a possible line but you have to
sacrifice the g3 pawn which again
creates a lot of crazy ideas for example
if F for captures on f3 on pass on G
captures and Queen captures on g3 it's a
it's a very bold pawn sacrifice for
example now Knights that e to and after
the Queen moves now you push f4 and the
whites position is very solid here but
still if you don't it's hard if it's not
in your preparation it's hard to decide
for something like this over the board
f5 is coming but still black will get a
very nice outpost for his Knight and c4
and it's a trade-off
so cross and prepares it instead of
pushing it for right away he plays
Knight to e2 which signifies that maybe
he wants to go for f4 now that the
knight guards the g3 pawn but also maybe
he's looking at night effort maybe h5 to
f6 also a very nice outpost for the
night either way usable replied with
castling queenside and now Carlsen goes
Knight to f4 instead of this idea and
now he could have some ideas of going
night to h5 to f6 or maybe just snapping
that bishop on e6 with Queen to g5
pinning the night as the King is still
on c1 and now keep the b1 by crossing
you also could try Knight to f1 here
with with the idea of just going rook to
h5 but then black can play h5 and now
White has a lot of interesting ideas for
example Bishop to h7 preventing the rook
from defending the h5 pawn now the
thread is a rook captures here but still
there are a lot of options for black to
some like Bishop to h6 now puts pressure
on the night here h4 will be a threat
and it's well it's it's really just a
crazy position so after Queen to g5 we
have King to be won by Carlsen first and
not
they spent pin to exist and now h5 buy
crucible and not allowing the rook to
ever reach the age five square and now
Knight to f1 here cousin has a lot of
interesting ideas like night to e3 to f5
just putting a Knight to f5 where black
will have to decide that whether to give
up this Bishop or not also just 93 maybe
a rook to h4 get this rook over to h1
and the wind eh five point if black can
even defend it
so black goes rook to h6 out putting
more defense here but also preparing to
maybe develop the bishop and get this
rook into the game as well with nice III
by Carson as prepared and now kink the
b8 as there will be a trade on f5 most
likely it's a nice prophylactic move
just getting the King out of the way and
here we have Knight to f5 by crossing
but it's a it's a really tricky position
for example if you go for the idea that
we mentioned rook H for preparing group
2 h1 the windy h5 pawn black gets a lot
of interesting contra play with c5 and
this is just a disgustingly crazy engine
line so I'm just going to show it
because after a c5 you get D captures
and c5 and now rook c8 preparing to
recapture the pawn here rook the h1 now
preparing to wind eh - and now d4
attacking the knight Knight to f5 now
you get rook captures on c5 attacking
the Queen and now you can go for this
Queen captures on c5 idea.i I said it
was a disgusting engine line so I hope
you were ready for it Bishop captures
Queen and now Knight captures on h6
Queen captures on h6 and the rook
captures on h5 and after the Queen moves
now you go for rook to e8 check and now
you can't move the King if you move the
King just Knight captures on e6 check
the King forms the Queen you have to
capture and now rook here wins back the
Queen leaves white in a better position
so after rook to e8 check you would have
to block it Knight the c8 and now you
just play rook to h5 and even though
black is up in material he has a four
two rooks he has a queen and the bishop
but White's position is extremely strong
and it's very hard for from black to
find some ideas here but of course
that's a that's a disgusting engine line
which I only showed because it was nice
but okay Knight to f5 by Carson
attacking the rook and here we have a
trade you don't really want to move the
rook some like rook each seven go under
the mask of the bishop here so why not
just grab it with Bishop captures an f5
Bishop captures on f5 and in the now
comes h4 now of course you cannot
capture because the knight would hang on
f4 so here night-night back to E - I
just getting in the night out of the way
now you are ready to capture on h4 and
here the situation on the clock is 45
minutes for constant in 21 minutes for
crucible with H captors and g3 rook
captures on h6 Bishop captures on h6 and
Dena comes in Knight captures and g3 so
the material on the board is equal the
bishops are of opposite colors and the
noun tonight the cc4 crucible gets a
beautiful outpost for his Knight so now
what's a constant plant here here Carson
goes to Bishop to d3 threatening to just
grab the Nightwind the c4 pawn and now
Knight the d2 with check with King to a
1 and the now comes Queen to f4 here
kuzu bow is threatening to win DF to
point to win the d4 pawn it's just all
very nicely placed but Carson has a very
nice defensive move Knight to f5 now
attacking the bishop here so if you just
capture the pawn you will lose the
bishop there and also the d4 point is
nicely protected so Bishop to g5 not
allowing the bishop to remain a target
and now nice the d6 constant creates a
monster night of his own and here the
situation on the clock is 40 minutes
Carlsen and ten minutes for for kuzu
both and here we have Queen captures on
f2 so coos will accept the challenge he
says I'm grabbing your pawn let's see
what you have Queen captures on f2 and
here across and spent 15 minutes
calculating all all of the ideas and he
in the end he played Queen to c3 but
just to show you how to Eisen is the
position is there are ideas like Knight
captures on b7
King captures on b7 and Bishop to a6
check King captures and now Queen
captures on c6 check came to a5 and now
before with Czech team capture some
before and now Queen to c5 Czech and
amazingly black can survive this attack
because there's no way to get the rook
into the game since well the v1 score is
covered by the knight so after King a4
you would have to settle for a perpetual
with Queen captures on a7 king would
just go back 25 check and now or you can
just go back engage 6 Queen to c6
checking gauge 7 Queen c7 check you
cannot win anything here since the
bishop is also guarding the rook so you
just have to go back winter c6 check and
it's it's a draw constant didn't like
this so the different was the idea of
Knight captures on b7 but there's also
the idea of Bishop f5 just cutting off
the Queen's defense of the f7 pawn now
threatening Knight captures over here
and then you would see g3 Knight
captures on f7 and rook to f8 attacking
the rook putting a pressure on the
bishop here Knight captures and g5
winning the bishop
rook captures on f5 with an attack on
the night and now rook captures and e2 a
very sneaky move as well there are a lot
of back ranked weaknesses for Magnus
Queen captures on d2 now you cannot
capture the Queen because you will get
made it after Luke to f1 you will have
to play Queen captures on f5 allow Queen
to c1 check block the check and now
Queen captures on g5 so this is one
other possibility where blackett has a
very dangerous g3 form but Magnus has a
past
EEP on so a lot of things to calculate
here like I said call the cross and
spend a whole 15 minutes on those crazy
variations and in the end he played
Queen to c3 he didn't like it he had
played play move that it doesn't draw
the game on the spot as well
no Kosovo is a very strong Ukrainian
grandmaster but still his 202 points
lower rated than Magnus but on the other
hand who isn't and cousin well as long
as he can keep winning chances he will
try and keep winning chances and here we
have looked to d7 it's the best move
defending f7 putting more defense to the
b7 point it's just an overall good move
situation on the clock this is move 30
25 minutes crossing six and a half
minutes who's above and they still have
to play 10 more moves to reach time
control
and here crawl someplace Quint the
before he he has to keep an eye on
everything but it's it's hard to do that
he's keeping around his d4 pawn but
kuzava finds a way to do it with a 5
it's not good to go after the g2 pond
right away then UV at night captures on
b7 route captures and now again Queen to
f8 check King to c7 and now you again
have black well Queen d6 check came to
b6 and we need to be for sure King Cecil
community 6 but it's interesting
coos Bob doesn't want a draw against
Magnus he feels that he's better here
and he is pushing for a win with a 5 now
getting the Queen away from the defense
of the d4 pawn with Queen captures an e5
across and there is no better move and
now we in captures on d4 and again what
do you do here offering a queen trade
something like this is not as
ill-advised Queen captures beat captures
and now f6 puts pressure on the e5 pawn
you cannot capture as you lose the night
so Carlson has to go for what Goethe
offered him you have to capture the
knight cross and captures it now the
idea is of course giving up the rook for
two pieces but there maybe is something
else so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the best move for
black in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations as
I did give a hint you know maybe there
is something better so congratulations
for for paying attention and for those
who just wants to enjoy the show
Queen captures on e5 this is the best
move and this gives a black well
excellent winning chances because
everything is now under attack the roof
is under attack the knight is under
attack Queen e1 is is in the air so if
you don't if you just move the rook
let's everybody one Queen captures here
happens and then you're in a here in a
very nice end game where you are up two
points this is a great in itself but
even with best defensive moves like
Knight to e4 as you cannot capture due
to Queen captures Queen you would still
play Bishop captures on B to Knight
capture somebody to and now after Queen
to g3 going after this pawn yes it's a
bishop and the night against the rook
you are up two points and it's very
likely that you will win another point
so after looking after sandy - Queen
captures an e5d best move in the
position but who's about very long time
he doesn't find if he plays Bishop
captures Andi - right away we have Queen
Catherine b2 by Carlson and only now
Queen captures on e5 but now it's a bit
different because the knight escapes via
the f5 square black black is still
better here but it is a bit bit easier
for Carlsen to play this and here we
have c5 so it's the best move just
preparing to start pushing your pawns
and here situation is 20 minutes
crossing a minute and a half for ku
Zubov and here Bushell back to be 1 for
calls and he doesn't want the bishop to
be the object of an attack when despawn
start marching forward and he has to try
create some sort of a defensive setup
with d4 by coup Zubov of course you have
to push her passport and now Queen to d3
just preventing the point for me to push
the c4 and now Queen to b5 15 seconds on
the clock for crucible he's preparing c4
Crossing goes Queen to g3 check with
came to a7 and now Queen captures on g4
just grabbing that pawn saying okay I
just wrapped the point if I grab maybe
another one then my bishop and Knight
are definitely worth your rook but still
with this bishop being so weak and
crossings background being so weak it
will be very hard and here we have d3
maybe a bit better was c4 just keeping
an option of playing d3 or c3 at some
point but okay we have D 3 by crucible
as like I said he's extremely low on the
clock few seconds on the clock and he
still has to play two more moves to
reach time control we have Knights the
e3 by cross and this is the the mood
that really brings crossings defense
alive because it prevents C for the
knight and the Queen are now guarding
the c-4 square also the D 1 square is
covered that's very important square as
it is the queening square we have Queen
to d4 offering the Queen trade attacking
the knight and now well cousin doesn't
want to trade Queens just yet Queen to
f3 I live in Queens on the board just
leaves him with more opportunities with
d2 that's already an extremely dangerous
pass pawn and Qasim
with night study 1 and here Quintus see
for just getting the Queen out of the
way preparing to get the rook into the
game if he can somehow get to this rook
let's say to h1 to threaten the night
here get the Queen to c1 then then he is
definitely winning this game but a
course and also has something to say
about this now he can try and trade
Queens let's say Quincy 3 Queen captures
you have to capture with the beep on you
can't move the knight and then after
rook e7 going after tonight you could go
king b2 and now let's say b5 you will
finally get to activate your pieces and
start playing this endgame so this is
one option for Magnus but he still
prefers the Queens on the board he goes
Queen to e3 prevents the rook to e7 so
the rook cannot infiltrate immediately
also put some pressure as the C pawn
cannot move at the moment I will rook
the d4 just that rook is now much better
protected here and you can finally go
Queen to see one with a three by Carlsen
creating some breathing room for the
king and now Queen the c1 attacking the
knight and we have Queen to b3 just
defending it also possible for Coulson
was if he wants to bail out you can just
play Queen to e7 give up the night and
then go again for this Queen captures
and c5 King g6 and Queen captures here
and even though Carson is a publisher of
the the past deep on is well more than
enough compensation for for the piece
but cousin prefers Queen to b3 just
setting up a nice defense and now comes
look back to d6 now kuzu bow wants to
bring this rook over to the B file to
create some threats along along along
there we have King to a2 and pinning it
now cousin wants to activate his bishop
and here we have c4
if work the b6 right away you have Queen
a4 check so after the king moves king b2
you're gonna play Queen Bishop to c2 and
now you have this beautiful defensive
setup where everything is protected
you're never getting rid of this night
here and well the night just nicely
guards the b2 upon so there are no made
threats possible here so we'll see for
by crucible and then now Queen back to
f3 you have to keep an eye on your night
here and now comes look to b6 again
putting pressure on the
on here and maybe preparing c3 c3 if you
can play this you should be you should
be very good because you cannot capture
with the night due to checkmate you can
have captured with the Queen because of
Queen captures night you will have to
capture with the pawn and then well a
white King will start feeling the draft
but Bishop f5 buckles and finally he's
able to activate his pieces and if he
can get to this Bishop to g4 maybe put
it to f3 to use it as an attacking piece
also keep an eye on g2 and also keep an
eye on the night here then the Queen can
finally be a fully activated situation
on the clock is 40 minutes Carlsen 8
minutes for for crucible so he really
burned a lot of time after after time
control and here he probably should have
gone for c3 we have B captures on c3 and
now look to a6 going after the a3 pawn
but here King b3 is just a disgusting
move to analyze especially with your
time on the clock ticking for example
rook captures King C for Luke a4 check
King d3 and how do you continue this
attack most likely the Queen will just
you know join join the action and pick
up the d2 opponent without the D to
point you're just worse so kuzu buff
doesn't like that with two and a half
minutes left on the clock he plays rook
to b5 his idea is I want to capture the
bishop and after the Queen captures I'll
just capture your knight on d1 but
Carlsen plays Queen to e3 check just
Rieman overs the Queen and prepares
Bishop to g4 so then the bishop will be
guarding the night with King to a6 and
now Bishop to g4 here kuzu both has one
minute on the clock and he has to figure
out a plate plan how to break through
with Queen to c2 just preparing Queen to
b3 as if you can get this pond to
capture on b3 then that will be
excellent for black with Quintus III by
Carlsen now called cross and is
confident in trading Queens after five
and a half hours of play Carson wants to
enter the endgame but crucible now
doesn't doesn't like the endgame and he
shouldn't as here white would be better
than an endgame but it is his best
chance he tries Queen to b3 check hoping
to get this Queen capture see capture
son b3 check King to be one and now
black is just completely winning because
these two points create a wall against
the white king Carson will not be able
to use his King you're just gonna get to
the rook into the game and it's gonna be
very painful for white so cross and of
course doesn't do this he just moves
back King to be won and here believe it
or not kuzu both played roped the five
but at the moment he pressed the clock
his time ran out so here he basically
flagged out he lost on time
but even without losing on time there is
a the position is not winning for
Carlsen and you can even pause the video
and try to find the best continuation
here but oh and I you know I encourage
you to do so so what would you play here
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting such a
such an elegant winning winning idea and
for those who just want to enjoy it so
it's actually Queen to f6 check now that
there are no threats on the Queen side
you can just pick up the pawn and that's
that's pretty much it for example King
h7 you can capture the pawn here and now
there are no tricks here if c3 now to
defend your look and also threaten mate
you have Queen to f2 check and after the
King moves and now you play Knight
captures on c3 and there are no problems
here because after d1 bring your queens
of the game Knight captures you will get
rook captures with Czech Bishop captures
Queen captures with check King to a two
you will get Queen to d5 check and there
is no perpetual because you can play b3
and the Queen is covering the second
rank so here it's three points against
one in a queen opponent game completely
winning for white of course what good
would have played this out if he didn't
lose on time and I'm not 100% sure if he
lost on time or resign but I'm pretty
sure he lost some time so if anyone can
you know confirm that I would be very
grateful but yeah definitely a tough
game for world champion Magnus Carlsen
in round one of the Isle of Man grants
with chess tournament even though his
opponent is 200 rating points a lower
rated than him it's never easy
especially its round one used to have to
get in the mood and everyone is
dangerous
there are no easy opponents and here a
cousin definitely felt it and black had
this beautiful opportunity here at this
point there were a lot of moves where
you could have gone better but this was
just this was just you know definitely
that moment were captured if he found
Quinn captors on e5 pretty sure pretty
sure we would have seen a scene as zero
a for Carlson and that he would lose his
I believe this is not 91 game winning
streak so he's coming very close to the
England's a 100 game winning streak
we'll see if he can if he can make it
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Pete
McDonald for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check
doing my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions there are so many
games being played 154 players so please
suggest games I can't really spot them
all myself and of course very quickly
very quickly we will be having our vote
on the next big saga so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day